-Our next guest is
an Oscar-nominated actor
who stars in the Netflix series
"The Umbrella Academy."
The third season
starts streaming June 22nd.
Let's take a look.
-Viktor,
we could go home tonight.
Okay?
And for the first time in days,
I'm feeling hope,
so please don't step on that.
-Okay.
Come on. We have to be
smarter about this.
We don't know enough
about the Sparrows.
-I've got you.
No one's gonna want to fight
against me and
my tiny badass brother.
-No more improvising, okay?
We do things together
from now on. Got it?
-Please welcome back to
the show Elliot Page, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Ahh.
-Hey.
-Welcome back.
-How's it going?
-This is a fantastic show
about adoptive siblings
with superpowers.
It's full of action.
The clip did not show that.
I feel like this is
a very spoiler-laden show.
So when someone like you comes
on to do press, they give us
a clip that does not tell
much about the show at all.
-Yeah, it's nice to keep it
exciting and full of surprises.
There's great twists and turns
this year.
So -- And I think it shows
the balance of the show,
and it's so fun to make
as an actor.
It's so fulfilling as an actor,
and, yeah, we have so much fun.
-You also play violin
on the show.
Is this a skill
you had to teach yourself?
Because it looks
very convincing.
-I most certainly
did not teach myself,
and I was pretty horrible at it.
In my defense, they say it's
the most difficult instrument
to learn,
which I very much understand.
[ Laughter ]
But I had an amazing teacher
and a fantastic double.
And I just...
-That seems like --
-...did my best.
-It seems like the second one
might be more helpful.
-Yeah. She was fantastic.
Imogen. Incredible.
So what a joy to listen
to her play on set.
Me? [ Clicks tongue ]
I'm sure the crew members
were probably ready
to walk off set.
-Right.
So, since the show started,
you, as an actor,
came out as trans,
and then your character
also came out as trans.
Were these conversations that
you got to have with the writers
about the journey
that your character took,
having lived
that experience yourself?
-Yeah, it was.
And really with Steve Blackman,
the showrunner of "Umbrella,"
who's just incredible
and such a wonderful person.
And so, when we first
talked about it,
he seemed really excited about
incorporating it into the show.
And an incredible writer,
journalist, author
Thomas Page McBee,
who I met doing a miniseries
called "Tales of the City,"
he wrote an extraordinary book
called "Amateur,"
which I highly recommend
everybody to read.
He was the first trans man
to box in Madison Square Garden.
And his book
and his work in general,
there's so much
about masculinity
and what it means
and exploring that.
So Thomas came on board
and helped out,
and I feel proud of it
and excited
for people to see it.
-One of the nice things is,
your siblings on the show,
when receiving the news
of the transition,
are very supportive and loving.
Was this something that you had?
I know you have run the gamut of
having to respond to reactions,
both positive or negative.
Were the people closest to you
in your real life
as supportive
as the people on the show?
-Yeah, absolutely. So --
And I feel really grateful
for that. [ Laughs ]
I think most people
weren't surprised or --
It's something
I'd been talking about
with a lot of people in my life.
-I think that is
really important to know,
which is -- So much
is being said about this issue
from people who aren't
experiencing in real time
or who don't know people
who go through it, right?
If you know a loved one,
this news probably comes
as less of a surprise
than those of us on the outside
would expect it to be received.
I know that since
you've come out as trans,
you've had to receive,
you know, from the strangers,
from people who don't know you
as a person,
some pretty negative reactions.
What has that journey
for you been like?
-[ Chuckles ]
Well, you know, what
I want to focus on right now
and has been so extraordinary
is the degree of joy
that I feel,
the degree of presence
that I feel.
I feel a way that I really
never thought possible
for a long, long time.
So that's really what I'm
focusing on embracing the most.
But, of course,
moments can be overwhelming.
Um...
I feel like it's one of those
things where it's so unfortunate
because it's like we're all
on the same team here.
You know?
Whether you're trans, non-bin--
you know,
gender-nonconforming, cis,
we all have these expectations
and these sort of limits
and constraints
because of, yes,
sort of people's obsession
with, you know, the binary
and how we're all
supposed to live our lives.
So, you know, to me,
it'd be so special for us
to all be able to connect
and talk about how similar
we are in all of our journeys.
-You wrote very beautifully
in "Esquire"
about the joy you feel now
and about how present you feel
in your body.
Do you feel like that's
making you a better actor?
I would imagine that
you had to get through so much
to do a performance
in the past,
and now it just must feel easier
to go out and do work.
-It does, yeah. I mean,
everything does. You know?
And that's obviously
a big component
and part of my life.
And, yeah, beautiful thing
to experience now,
because a lot of the time,
my life was just trying
to move forward.
And so getting to embrace
the experience
as much as I get to now.
And I think it's made me
better in so many facets,
like, as a person,
I think, as a friend,
and, you know, relationships.
-I think you both embrace it
and you've probably
had it forced upon you
to be an activist,
to some degree,
about this
really important issue.
And you've spoken about
how you want to approach it
with empathy, which I think
is really beautiful
and probably more effective.
Do you find --
Does it come easy to you
to approach this all
with empathy?
-Not always. Um, but...
[ Laughter ]
I think --
Yeah, I think, in some ways.
And I think when you do --
I reflect on certain
very difficult times in my life,
certain struggles
and obstacles and all that.
And I think, ultimately
getting through that,
I think it really
deepens your empathy.
And I think of the times
in my life
where I was
the most uncomfortable,
where I was the most unwell
are the times
when I was the most angry
and I was the most unkind
to myself or self-righteous
or all of those things.
And so it's just --
It's improved my life
drastically.
And, um --
And I hope, you know --
I hope maybe people
who do have an issue with me
can maybe try
and hear that
and embrace that on some level.
-Well, personally,
it is really lovely to hear
how much joy it's brought you.
And thank you so much
for sharing it with us
and continuing to make it a
story other people can hear.
Really nice to see you again.
-You too, Seth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Elliot Page, everyone.
The first season
of "The Umbrella Academy"
starts streaming
June 22nd on Netflix.